[Musik]
nicht jeder hund will wirklich
gestreichelt werden allerdings herzlich
willkommen meine damen und herren ich
heute zu einem neuen blog es ist ein
scheiß wetter also bewölktes wetter aber
bewirkt heißt scheiße das hier ist ein
boot geschäft das brot gar nicht
wirklich foto steht hier ein bisschen
schief ja dir gefällt dann auch auf
jeden fall sieht jetzt bereits im titel
eingeladene freunde wir stellen heute
mal wieder instagram bilder nach bevor
das ganze allerdings passiert wenn ich
sagen machen wir uns erstmal auf 60 eure
eltern selbstverständlich auf
beigebracht haben ist es wichtig dass
man den tag mit einem ausgewogenen und
gesunden frühstück dorfmitte die sowieso
gold auf den zähnen haben
wieso gibt es auch neue schokolade von
donat ist meiner
skurril 1000 leute was das die bitte von
fact du kaufst diese brötchen einen
denkt okay wir sind kanada auf diesen
folge sondern in der intro 7
und es ist einfach süß wie sonst was ich
wollte gesund leben jetzt sich zum
frühstücken süßes rosinenbrötchen
das liebste ist verrückt ich gut dass
ein bisschen schneller erleben aufessen
hallo das ist keine frage
hallo wie stehen sie zum thema am strand
am sand ist die sache heute nicht hinten
thema sand am strand nicht viel besser
nicht weil sie die wahl hätten eine
gabel immer gabi nennt oder würden die
sich eine andere sportart hilfen für den
hause bitte schaut euch die sushi
[Applaus]
betrieb aber solche schieber jungen
alter diese sog
okay ihr seid jetzt im blog wie heißt
denn euer install com and laser luca
alter alle folgen dann aber alle ihr
folgen
er trat schon gesehen habe sind wir
draußen unterwegs also die liebe jule
und ich wir sind draußen unterwegs
da sind wir sind ja wir sind auf
kinderspielplatz allerdings ist deswegen
ganz gut hat wird schaukeln
ich besitze ich eben schaukeln wir haben
uns allerdings hier versammelt freunde
weil wir instagram bildern darstellen
wollten also ich habe sieben für juden
ich habe sieben tagen bilder vom
schulchor ausgesucht und platz dann
wieder für mich raus und das heißt jude
wieder ein gentleman anfang mit dem
ersten euro oder das foto das du hast es
darstellen soll ist es dass hier von
felix der hier leute ihr könnt den
kommentaren ab
die posen im moment danach gemacht hat
das ist eine finale pose also das hier
ist das foto von felix gegen die bei
einem festival und jule macht das ganze
so nach du musst das erst mal andersrum
machen die oder was man jetzt sogar dass
gar keine wasserflaschen der hand
du bist ja schon flasche genug machen
und musste erst mal einen schuh
ausziehen was ich tue und ich wusste
eine chance ja dann also wer den neuen
merkel vor stellt also freunde hier
das war ganz schön mutig so das handy
tue ich mir hier nochmal zu einloggen
und mir alles gut ich drehen und video
aber die sind nicht so hochwertig das
nächste foto was ich hier für dich auch
von einer unglaublich kennen sollte ist
und frei und dieser hier ein bild von
jule also jude hat das foto noch mal
angeschaut sie entscheidet sich hier
anstatt dieser traum
also sieht das foto aus gehört sich hier
natürlich für eine couch entschieden
wie bei jonathan ross war das glaube ich
und hier sehen wir jule das ja doch wie
sieht man ihr das foto ist kann man
schon so einloggen
[Musik]
gott hat das kind eine geile karte warum
habe ich meine eltern rumgefahren alter
ist das geil ich gehe auf die bank der
club ran
genau den einen arm so den anderen so
nicht brücke wird juli nächstes foto was
du hier nach stellen soll es von einer
künstlerin die du sehr bewundert und
zwar von dieser hier
katy perry juli gibt katy perry ich
hatte zeit mir das foto hier dann eben
genau das steht schon mal richtig runter
muss ich ein bisschen mehr zu mir drehen
genau das eine beiden die das andere
beiden nach vorne
genau und jetzt guckst du nach links
also luxus ein luca fürs nächste welt
brauchen wir jemanden wie dich ein
pfosten
für dich habe ich hier ein brot nur eine
sängerin war wieder ausgeglichen
nicht dass das foto was jetzt darstellen
sollten also ihr seht das foto jetzt mal
oben rechts in der ecke eingeblendet sag
einfach wenn du fertig bist wenn du es
einloggen möchte
passt ja kann man so einloggen ich
musste gerade schon akku tauschen weil
der lehrer war und ich habe mal einen
akku mit der wir nicht bescheuert aber
wir machen mal schnell weiter
das nächste bild natürlich in busch
setzen im busch ja da passt das nicht
george bush und den anderen
[Musik]
juli das nächste instagram bild ist von
einer person da würde ich wirklich sagen
die ist genauso breit wie du und zwar
dieser hier ja der rock johnson tanks
dass man die übungen ein paar sekunden
später ja sieht eher so aus dass willst
du gerade harley fahren oder versuchen
zu fliegen aber manchmal videos
einloggen würdest wird genau so machen
wir einfach so
so hätten sich auch mal hinlegen
fußboden warum ich muss mich schon auf
die sexy beach co aber mein gott haben
den ganzen arm voll mit diesem sprint
muss beim proben müssen wir raus
strecken und letztes bild was ich für
juli vorbereitet habe ist ab juli bei
ihr hier auf st keine ahnung was jetzt
am strand oder so also ja das muss sogar
machen ihr seht das foto links
eingeblendet freunde juli versucht das
ganze jetzt mal derart nachzustellen und
so wie es nach stellen ok und hat noch
ein foto vorbereitet was ich noch machen
soll die sache ist allerdings dass bei
dem foto die flaschen mit dem spiel ist
außerdem außer mir noch eine flasche
habe sich deswegen gehen wir etwas essen
und ich werde da dann das foto nach
stellten auf dem weg zum restaurant hat
mir gerade so ein schild entdeckt
irgendwie dass hier was soll das
bedeuten denn sie eine mutter sind und
kinder haben und spazieren gehen wollen
dann bitte daran ok danke
rogers
in der moment der fall offen und lehrer
deshalb voll und sie zu und damit haben
jetzt alle instagram wieder nachgestellt
freunde und 4
tierisches bild lachsfilet mit
mediterranem gemüse julia hat einfach
keine ahnung was ein spiegelei mit
irgendwas darunter vorhin als ich dieses
bild auf der bank gestellt ob man sich
ja schon das sind so richtig viele
ameisen und jetzt noch mehr und jetzt
einfach so was mal vier weisen dass da
sind die leute seht ihr das alte das
ganze übel stil einfach übereinander was
geht er ab bei den ameisen leute freunde
so dreckig ohne schwere spielwelt uno du
bist so hat verkackt nur wenige minuten
später hätte was hast du denn jetzt hier
ich hätte gewonnen was hast du denn hier
bist du bescheuert leute die hatte
irgendwie zehn karten auf der hand ich
hab nur noch 22
ich habe zwei dann ziehst du halt vier
guck mal hier hält sich aus so ein
schlechter verlierer ich erst mal gern
würde so schlecht bist du bist alles
meine taktik ist eine große auswahl
jetzt zu sagen wir haben schöne zähne
und leute die sonne geht immer weiter
runter also da sieht man ja gar keine
sonder was wird immer dunkler draußen
und unser abend besteht eigentlich nur
darauf dass juliane verliert
jojo ich habe es gewonnen und somit aus
dem paradies getan nicht klar weil ja
hallo hier ist der korridor der sich
youtuber nennen ich schneide hier gerade
den blog den er gerade sieht und jetzt
kann aufgefallen ich habe jetzt den
anfang es zu sagen deswegen jetzt los
und biss wie beim morgen
[Musik]